So, we can do another example of defining a recursive
procedure. And the goal this time is to take in
a string, and determine whether or not it's a palindrome.
What a palindrome is, is a string that reads the same
way, forwards and backwards. So, an example of a palindrome
would be level. If we read level forwards, we get
level If we read it backwards, we get exactly the
same thing. Another example of a palindrome would be the word,
the single letter a. If we read a forwards, we
get a. If we read a backwards, we also get
a. In fact, any single letter must be a palindrome.
The empty string is also a palindrome. If we read
the empty string forward, we have the empty string, if
we read the string backward, we also have empty string.
So, our goal is to define a procedure that will
take any string as input and output true if that string
is a palindrome. I am going to view, give you a few hints how
to do this, but start thinking on your own, if you can think
of a way to define a procedure that tests whether or not a
string is a palindrome. So, this is a pretty tough question. See how far
you can get on your own, but I'm going to provide some hints before
we make the quiz. So, the first hint is, we want to think
of what it means to be a palindrome. To try to formalize that
definition, if we knew easy ways to produce the reverse of the string, and
check if it's equal. Well that would be an easy way
to solve this, and in fact there are ways to do that
in Python. But we haven't seen them yet. And I want to
have you think about ways to do this palindrome that don't depend
on that. So, that means we need to think about a
way of defining a palindrome in terms of simpler things. So, the
first thing to notice is, there's one simple case where we know
right away whether a string's a palindrome. So, we should think that
that might be our base case. When we do
procedures on numbers our base case is often something
that deals with a number like zero or one,
a small number. When we do recursive procedures on strings,
it's more likely that our base case is going to
be the simpler string, which is the empty string. So,
we know that if the input is an empty
string, the result of this palindrome is true. The empty
string is a palindrome. What if the input's not an empty
string. Well then, one way to solve that would be to
look at the first letter of the string, and look at
the last letter of the string. If those two are equal.
Well, then it might be a palindrome. It's a palindrome if
all the ones left over in the middle are also a
palindrome. So, this is how we could break the question of
testing whether a string's a palindrome into smaller steps, that our
recursive case is going to test the first and the last
character of the string, see if those are equal, so if
our recursive case. We're going to test the first and the last
characters of the string. If those don't match, we know it's
not a palindrome. That means we know the result is
false. If they do match, we're not done. We need to
check the rest of the string. And that means, we need
to check the middle of the string, if that's a palindrome.
And because we're able to define this recursively, remember that
we're defining the procedure is_palindrome, but we can do this test
assuming that we've already defined it. In order to check whether
the middle of the string is a palindrome we can use
the procedure that we're defining. This is like we were
able to use factorial to define factorial in terms of a
smaller number. In this case, we're defining a palindrome in terms
of the smaller string. So, I hope this is enough for
you to get started, so see if you
can define the code for is_palindrome, keeping in mind
that we can break it down into these two cases where if it's empty, we know it's
a palindrome right away, if it's not empty,
well, we need to look at that first and
last characters. If they do match, we also
need to look at the middle of the string.